comment vous allez j'espère vous allez
bien aujourd'hui on va se parler d'un
smartphone qui est très cool qui était
présenté il ya quelques temps il est
enfin temps de vous en parler
c'est ce modèle là c'est le aux ports et
docks et z je vous ai parlé déjà dû au
port et nos quatre pros vous invite à
aller voir la vidéo je vais parler du
aux ports et docks 4 et aujourd'hui on
parle du petit frère le petit frein la
série c'est le modèle z modèles z il est
bien il fait de jolies promesses alors
les promesses vous êtes tous notés sur
un pas pire que j'aime bien connaître
les promesses des marques pour voir
derrière ce qu'il en est ce que les
promesses sont tenues de trop mais ce
sont 100 ma feuille en promesses
on nous promet de la 5g on nous promet
un écran mais quand autres
affranchissement de 120 hertz donc de la
fluidité et une très bonne expérience
sur ce que vous allez bien navigué sur
nos smartphones on va regarder si c'est
vrai et on nous promet également une
double caméra de celle fille on va voir
si elles sont intéressantes à voir si
elles sont pertinentes puis surtout on
va regarder tout le reste voir si ce
smartphone écoute s'il est fait pour
vous et ça on fait juste après ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me suis mis dehors dehors il peut
presque beau il fait 3 degrés si vous
voyez devenir bleu vous inquiétez pas je
sais pas si vous avez suivi un peu si
vous connaissez la marque copeaux ou pas
c'est une marque qui se développe de
plus en plus un très très gros acteurs
sont les plus gros acteurs aujourd'hui
au niveau de la téléphonie mobile au
niveau du monde entier pour partie d'un
très gros groupe je passe un petit peu
l'histoire n'a eu notamment l'année
dernière l'arrivée de flagship avec le
finepix de pros y ait eu plein d'autres
modèles également dans la gamme et put
arriver en deuxième partie d'année
ces galeries no 4 et locales vraiment
axé sur la photo et surtout sur la vidéo
alors l'orénoque athlètes c'est le petit
frère dont il dira beaucoup moins loin
que lorenzo quatre pros qui permettra de
faire des clichés très intéressant
d'aller beaucoup plus loin en terme de
vidéo et notamment au niveau de la
stabilisation une fois de plus aller
voir ma vidéo et celui là il est bien
parce que ça me permet de rentrer dans
la gamme renault 4 à un prix qui
beaucoup plus bas puisque le tarif ici
la reine appris par coeur 379 euros de
base vous pouvez trouver à 329 euros une
fois de plus vous avez les liens en bas
dans la description regardez-moi ça
comme c'est mignon un vrai petit miroir
on se voit dedans
bon d'un autre côté ça c'est aussi une
fois de plus que tout ce qu'on connaît
qu'on retrouve sur des smartphones dans
cette gamme de prix donc rien de bien
surprenant là dessus vous avez un dos
aux polymères c'est à dire on est ici
sur un dos en plastique trouve qu'il
fait malgré tout son essai alors
attention ici on le voit on a les
petites traces de doigts on a les
reflets mais de toute façon pense à
mettre une coque pendant le protéger
pour éviter les déconvenues ce qui est
sympa j'aime bien c'est que vous avez
des petits arrondi ici sur le côté donc
en termes de prise en main c'est bien
plutôt grave les finitions sont plutôt
bien faite de la part de au pot là
dessus il est pas très lourd à peine 184
g et surtout ce qui se passe à côté vous
avez un bouton qui fait office de
capteur d'empreinte digitale qui les
verrous très rapidement donc ça c'est
très bien qu'on va repérer tout et vous
le voyez c'est que vous avez ici un
double module photo on va regarder s'il
est pertinent dans quelques instants et
puis à l'arrière surtout vous avez
quatre petits objectifs
une fois de plus on va regarder la
configuration un peu plus loin et je
compte au pour dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire alors ce
qui est sympa c'est que vous avez quand
même ici un très grand écran on est sur
un écran de 6.50 7 pouces c'est du lcd
on est sur une techno c'est la ltps 2400
parmi celles à 400 pixels par pouce
rien de bien surprenant par contre ce
qui est intéressant c'est le taux de
rafraîchissement ici au pot nous annonce
un taux de rafraîchissement qui peut
aller jusqu'à du 120 hertz vous et
pouvoir le retrouver juste en dessous
ici dans la fréquence d'actualisation
par défaut ce que je vous conseille de
rester en sélection automatique comme ça
ils vénèrent switcher automatiquement en
fonction des besoins vous allez pouvoir
avoir ne vous mettez pas tout le temps
ensemble à ce que vous allez venir
consommer davantage au niveau de votre
batterie ni en 90 après 66 vous
souhaitez c'est ce qui est plus
classique
et là vous allez consommer le moins au
niveau de votre batterie après un autre
pendu sous conseille de faire c'est de
venir réchauffer votre écran vous venez
moduler la température de couleur moi
j'ai mis sur plus chaud par défaut moi
je trouve un petit peu froid comme
américain vraiment sur le bleu c'est pas
super super sinon vous avez un autre
mode c'est le confort des yeux la
hautière davantage sur le jaune mais ce
sera quand même beaucoup plus reposant
est beaucoup plus agréable bon pour ma
part ça va être ça et ça va être le mode
plus chaud un ratio 29e et à l'avant
vous avez un verre quand une gorilla
glass 3 plus bien d'écran qui certifiait
lutter contre la lumière bleue ce que je
veux me reprocher au niveau du design du
smartphone
eh bien c'est ce grand module photo
alors je sais que au pot n'est pas le
premier à le faire il ya d'autres
marques qui le font mais ce que je
reproche et voyez ça fait quand même
beaucoup de places déjà lorsque vous
avez une toute petite bulle ça prend de
la place à tout de suite c'est beaucoup
plus proéminent je vous le montre sur
une vidéo pour vous puissiez vous en
rendre compte regarder ça prend quand
même de la place sur le côté et voit les
bons je trouve ça un peu dommage alors
on finit par s'habituer mais bon malgré
tout c'est pas idéal
on est sur un smartphone qui est dans
l'entrée du milieu de gamme entre 300 à
400 euros donc on va pas s'attendre à
voir un smartphone qui fait des
merveilles au niveau de l'expérience
audio haut parleur mono parleurs qui se
situe juste en dessous c'est un très
très grand classique là dessus vous
allez retrouver également du bluetooth
5.1 pour venir à péret vos casques sans
fil vos petits bugs et notamment les
écouteurs de hope aux skis et conserver
une fois de plus dans cette gamme de
tarifs ça c'est normal c'est la prise
jack comment pouvoir retrouver sur le
dessous par contre là où ça devient
intéressant c'est au niveau du
processeur ici on va retrouver un
processeur médiathèque c'est le demand
city 800 alors je sais pas si vous le
connaissez
c'est un équivalent de stains dragonne
765 on est sur un processeur milieu de
gamme qui fonctionne bien qui épaulait
pas 8 gigas de ram une techno qui
fonctionne bien c'est le lay plénière 4x
et vous avez 128 go de stockage en ufs
2.20 aussi très classique qui marche
très bien mais ici non extensible vous
n'avez pas pouvoir rajouter de stockage
grâce à une carte microsd une des
grosses promesses qui ai fait ça avec
des smartphones d'entrée milieu de gamme
c'est la partie de l'autonomie avec des
très grosses batteries alors on monte
jusqu'à des batteries aujourd'hui de
5000 millions par an voire 6000 mis en
période chez certains fabricants ici on
a une batterie assez classique c'est une
batterie 4000 militaires alors rassurez
vous
a néanmoins de quoi faire un smartphone
qui tiendra une journée une journée de
missives d'être extrêmement lite on peut
pousser jusqu'à deux jours mais là
vraiment vous êtes vraiment mais
vraiment vraiment relax et vous avez en
plus à l'intérieur de cette jolie boîte
je veux mourir comme ça je montre tout
en même temps vous avez regardez vous
êtes dans les coulisses vous voyez tout
comme ça un bloc de charge de 18 watts
qui est inclus c'est de la recharge
rapide alors je passe si vous êtes
coutumier de au pot non je vous reçois
je vous explique propose qu'ils ont
c'est de la voulte charge c'est leur
système de charges extrêmement rapide
qui vous permet de recharger votre
smartphone le plus vite possible
ici comme on les sent tout petit frère
de la gamme eh bien on a pas que bush on
n'a pas de vous charger arrive même plus
à parler on va avoir de larges hanches
l'a6 et de l'a10 hui on va t'on un bloc
de charge de 18 mois donc il faudra un
peu plus vous armer de patience mais on
est dans les standards actuels une fois
de plus donc ici rien de surprenant vous
allez recharger 2-0 à 30% en 37 minutes
et de 0 à 100% en un peu moins de deux
heures faut-il de recharger à 100% je ne
suis pas sûr pour moi l'idéal c'est de
rester entre 20 à 80% et ça je voulais
déjà dit dans une précédente vidéo où je
vous parle des bons usages par rapport à
la batterie des smartphones je vous
invite à aller là bas
à noter ici que vous n'avez non plus pas
de charge sans fil un point que je
beaucoup ici c'est toute la partie
logicielle vous tournez sur color os 7
points de base et sur un android 10
color os vous avez plein d'options plein
de tous les côtés ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est de venir un
fouille et de venir fouiner dans tous
les paramètres pour me retrouver ce qui
vous intéresse que ce soit sur des
outils pratiques que ce soit sur les
réglages de votre écran enfin y'a pas
mal de petites choses qui sont très
intéressantes alors plus vous allez
avoir un smartphone haut de gamme chez
au pot et plus vous aurez d'options mais
déjà comme ça croyez moi vous avez de
quoi faire l'espace de jeu clonage
d'applis si vous le souhaitez toute la
gestion de vos applis qui se situe juste
ici ont renvoyé c'est très complet
c'est bien et personnellement j'aime
beaucoup parlons maintenant de la partie
photo ça sympa qui est super intéressant
quand vous prenez votre smartphone et
que vous le regardez vous voyez quatre
capteurs l'arrière boyer deux capteurs à
l'avant où il dit ça y est j'ai six
caméras c'est merveilleux c'est pour
faire plein de belles choses
ça c'est le discours marketing la
réalité est un petit peu autres en fait
vous n'avez pas si caméra
potentiellement intéressant que vous en
avez deux pas non allez je suis un peu
méchant vous en année 3 vous avez pas
moins de quatre capteurs à l'aria
premiers capteurs qui est intéressant
c'est le capteur principal c'est votre
48 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.7 soit l'équivalent de 25 mm ici
stabilisation électronique uniquement
vous avez un dutra
en tant que c'est un 8 mégapixels couvre
f 2.2 avec un champ de vision au 119 de
greyson équivalent de 16 mm
stabilisation électronique également qui
vous avez deux petits capteurs récit de
2 mégapixels le premier c'est du mot de
crocs pour le mode portrait pour faire
vos noir et blanc qui ouvre à f 2.4
hockey et le deuxième qui l'a également
pour le mode portrait avec un effet
vintage pour autant vous dire que sur
les quatre que vous avez ici en réalité
vous en avez deux qui sont intéressants
ça va être le capteur principal et ça va
être votre ultra grand-angle et surtout
votre capteur principal votre 48
mégapixels permettra de venir zoomer en
x 2 vous venez zoomer dans l'image sans
trop de perte de qualité pourrait coûter
jusqu en x 5
bon voilà il faut 10 apic carrément
message donc le résultat dans quelques
instants vous avez essayé de la vidéo
ultra stap on peut filmer jusqu en 4k à
30 images par seconde
or donc se faire un bout de vidéo de
test alors je suis sur les caméras de
celle fille et maintenant on va se
tester de l'autre côté là on le fait
avec une stabilisation un petit peu
classique s'est stabilisé c'est pas mal
regardez et vous avez un mode ultra
stabiliser ça c'est l'ultra stabilité et
c'est ouf parce que je vois vraiment le
décalage à l'écran parce que quelque
chose apparaît vraiment le traitement
logiciel derrière ça c'est assez
impressionnant quand même ça marche
quand même plutôt pas mal
on revient sur l'instable normale aura
notamment droit à un petit peu plus
sombre plus de voir à ce que sa vie
comme c'est tout mignon
dites moi ce que vous en pensez aux
commentaires qu'on retrouve et ça vous
paraît bien ou pas je ferai venir
mais là bon là je ne suis pas sûr
honnêtement mais ça va être brut et aux
propos hausse apic un petit peu les yeux
ça pique un peu les yeux et à l'avant
ici vous avez deux caméras une première
caméra c'est votre caméra principale de
celles fils une 16 mégapixels couvre f
2.0
la deuxième c'est une caméra de
profondeur qu'il apporte votre portrait
de 2 mégapixels touvre f 2.4 une fois de
plus là-dessus la deuxième caméra pour
moi ne sert vraiment pas à grand chose
regarde le résultat dans quelques
instants il vous pouvez venir faire en
plus des vidéos ici en 1080p jusqu'à 30
images par seconde
regardons tout ce que disent ces photos
là on est sur le capteur principal ça
marche très bien
48 mégapixels on s'en fout c'est la
limite du nombre de pixels mais par
contre ce qui compte c'est ça marche
bien vous voyez bien les nuages dans le
ciel vous voyez bien le bleu vous voyez
bien les zones qui seront absentes
normalement un peu plus foncé sur le bas
on voit bien toutes les parties plus
éclairée une très très très bonne
gestion de la lumière là dessus donc ça
fonctionne bien on n'est pas sur un des
capteurs les plus dingues mais je puis
vous assurer que pour un smartphone de
l'a 350 euros à peu près en tout cas il
fait très bien son boulot l' ultra
grand-angle et pas mal n'est pas
déformant on perd en précision on voit
ici au niveau du côté des bâtiments
récupère un petit peu de boer
il faut savoir que si vous n'avez
absolument aucune stabilisation donc si
vous bouger un petit peu tout de suite
ça risque de se voir on sera un peu
moins bon au niveau de la gestion de la
lumière mais une fois de plus cela tu ne
seras du point de détail et vu qu'on est
sur un ultra grand temps que c'est pas
mal on peut venir nous met ensuite en x
2 pourquoi pas vu convient ou mais sur
un capteur de 48 mégapixels et bien sûr
un x 2 ça ira et l'image ne va pas se
dégrader
par contre si vous passez en x 5 tout de
suite c'est un peu moins bon et il a le
x 10 bon bah voyons on peut y aller mais
je vous le recommande vraiment pas on
continue ensuite avec un contre-jour et
bien écoutez sauf que c'est vraiment
bien
on voit bien tous les nuages autour du
soleil on voit bien le contour des
bâtiments on voit bien les façades
il ya une très très très bonne gestion
ici tout votre plage dynamique les
couleurs sont bien préservés
on a bien les peintres là sur la droite
au niveau du bâtiment fin pour moi c'est
vraiment bien et ce capteur 48
mégapixels est très bien intégré il
marche très très très bien sur l'ultra
grand temps il a un peu plus de mal mais
malgré pour garder on voit bien toute la
façade on va bien tous les petits nuages
à côté donc le boulot est fait et quand
même plutôt pas mal fait on voit qu'il
ya ensuite là on vient se rapprocher
avec le x 2 c'est un peu moins bon tout
de suite et le x 5 ans d'oubli on
continue ici on a le soleil dans le dos
c'est très très bon voit bien tous les
détails dans les nuages une fois de plus
le cas dans l'immédiat pixels marche
très bien l'ultra grand angle à dien on
voit la différence de colorimétrie
regarder le ciel
là on a un bleu un peu plus foncée là on
a un bleu un peu plus pastel est paraît
il en voit un peu plus le gris foncé sur
le bâtiment et on le perd
de l'autre côté donc les différences de
colorimétrie entre l'ultra grand temps
les quatre principales mais là dessus
c'est une fois de plus normal en x 2
c'est très bien ça lisse un peu et on le
voit un s'est pas complètement dingue
mais c'est quand même malgré tout bien
le x 5 ans d'oubli l x 10.6 sorte se
marrer quand vous voyez une fois de plus
48 mégapixels ça marche
ultra grand angle à peu près le foie et
de why not mais on commence
effectivement à voir qu'à toute une
partie qui va être un peu plus lissé is
it ce qui n'est pas anormal c'est tout
le traitement logiciel qu'on va
retrouver de ce côté là le x 5 compliqué
il faut 10 c'est rigolo demande oublie
là j'ai passé faute aux conditions de
faible luminosité sorbonne lui alors
voyez comme vous n'avez absolument
aucune stabilisation et bien ça devient
un prêt si vous allez vérifier un petit
peu plus loin alors là c'est moi avec le
mode nuit
il n'y a aucune stabilisation ça vient
de faire un espèce de lissage c'est
vraiment pas terrible il y avait un peu
moins de lumière mais il n'est pas de
lui que je peux vous dire c'est que la
photo nue ça va vraiment pas être
terrible
une fois de plus celle de luminosité
regarder le rendu c'est vraiment pas
beau du tout là on serait le mode
portrait alors notre portrait il a un
petit peu de mal quand même j'ai une
tête de cadavres à là-dessus déjà on le
voit on voit que la gestion des couleurs
est pas terrible il en est sur un
capteur de 2 mégapixels donc rien n'est
pas normal c'est vraiment pas terrible
il a du mal sur le côté c'est vraiment
pas beau pas beau pas beau du tout
deuxième essai là c'est pareil ça se
passe de teint cireux qui est vraiment
horrible
on continue ici une fois de plus fois et
c'est pas ouf
il arrive mieux à détourer mais c'est
pas extraordinaire là il un peu de mal
derrière l'oreille au quotidien avec la
mode portrait en noir et blanc où est la
limite j'ai un peu moins de ces armes là
dessus c'est moins pire
et là on vient pousser sur des effets
avec une colorimétrie dessus ça vient
booster un peu les couleurs mais il ya
un côté faye qui à côté lisse junte
inquiets malgré tout un peu terne et
c'est pas extraordinaire
et là on est sur la caméra de sel fille
alors cette caméra de celle ci bien
voyez la qualité pas complètement dingue
il un petit peu de mal au niveau des
plages dynamique la couleur n'est pas
extraordinaire
moi je suis pas très fan et là je vous
ai fait le bot portrait avec la caméra
de saïfi bas et moi c'est pareil je n'ai
pas particulièrement
et lorsqu'on vient complexifier eh bien
voyez fois le détourage au niveau des
doigts et pas ouf
il ya un petit peu de mal rien aberrant
n'oublions pas que nous sommes sur une
caméra de celle fit un smartphone qui
viennent évidemment et de la 5g ça fait
partie des promesses aujourd'hui la 5g
est arrivé donc vous pouvez souscrire un
abonnement ça j'ai d'ailleurs dit moi
vous est-ce que vous avez pris un
abonnement cette algérie ce que vous
pensez qu'en 2021 vous allez prendre un
abonnement 5 j'ai marqué le mort bas en
commentaire ici vous pouvez donc à céret
deux cartes sim pouvait avoir de la 5g
très facilement vous avez en plus du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé par
contre ici pas de certification ip
néanmoins au pot nous assure que notre
smartphone va être résistant à la
poussière et aux éclaboussures donc si
vous badinant largué commencent à
pleuvoir c'est pas besoin de le cacher
sous votre veste c'est vrai quand même
plutôt bien se passer
personnellement c'est un smartphone que
j'aime bien je trouve assez intéressant
je trouve que au pot a bien bossé bien
réussi son smartphone surtout la partie
photo qui est la partie qui va
m'intéresser le plus que je trouve bien
réussi au niveau du capteur principal
l'ultra grand tante pourquoi pas sur
certains usage en extérieur quand il
était vraiment beau la caméra de celle
ci on peut mais au delà de saab
on est un peu limité le fait d'avoir une
vidéo super stabiliser ça c'est aussi un
atout mais je ne suis pas sûr que si on
veuille un smartphone pour faire de la
vidéo
bien connue sur le reno kad z je
trouvais aussi l'expérience a le taux de
rafraîchissement s'en va être plutôt
bien c'est pas là on aura la meilleure
expérience pour le gaming mais une fois
de plus on est sur un smartphone à 379
euros qu'on peut trouver à 329 euros
donc voilà il faut bien restituée il
faut raison gardée par rapport à ça
l'expérience globale est plutôt
convenable smartphone fonctionne bien il
est rapide il est réactif vous avez une
belle capacité de stockage donc si vous
cherchez un très joli smartphone ou
autour de 379 329 euros et 350 euros on
va se le mettre dans cette dans cette
gamme de prix là eh bien mon avis le
reno kad z peut vraiment être fait pour
vous d'autant plus que au pot maîtrise
vraiment bien sa copie au niveau de la
photo il a su c'est un très bel atout
d'autant plus que c'est très compliqué
dans cette gamme de prix parce que vous
avez beaucoup d'acteurs de très gros
acteurs des acteurs majeurs donc je
trouve ça bien que au pot soit
positionné avec un smartphone que je
trouve en tout cas bien réussi bien
finie beau sympa qui a forcément
quelques faiblesses mais à 379 329 euros
on ne peut pas tout avoir
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez ce smartphone est ce qu'il
pourrait vous tentez ce qui pourrait
vous intéresser ce que vous avez déjà eu
un smartphone de au pot et est-ce que
celui là le au port et nos cases elle
pourrait vous tenter mark et moi tout ça
en bas en commentaire quand on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler tech du bisou de l'amour du lot
il ya très vite ciao